[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting
we're going to expand your vocabulary
with some words that maybe you never use
you know sometimes you fall out of use
of words that you really liked at one
point you need to be reminded of them
sometimes you need to be schooled on an
entirely new word that needs to become a
part of your vocabulary toolbox
sometimes you forget whether prohibited
means you can do it or you can't do it
right
that's a quote
so we ask you to tell us what are your
favorite words a word that you just find
yourself going back to maybe it makes
you smile maybe it's it's just perfect
for something that you find yourself
needing to use it for a lot so I I'm
pretty hopeful about this because I do
have a strong belief do you think you're
going to find some new words yeah my I
have a strong belief in a vocabulary
toolbox you get yourself in this these
kind of ruts to the things you say
and you pick up and you throw down what
the people around you are saying and
sometimes it's good to just mix it up a
little bit and have you noticed that it
has become harder to retain
new words
like it's harder to expand your book
vocabulary because I have noticed age
you think we're degrading uh well I mean
if we're the normal folk yeah we are
degrading I mean mid-40s I'm just saying
the thing I don't I'm not saying that I
am necessarily noticing that I'm
forgetting words what I am noticing is
that I'll be like that gum I
what does that word mean I had this
exact same
scenario
three months ago when I came across this
word and I specifically remember taking
the word looking at the definition and
moving it thinking about it into a new
space in your brain and now I'm back
here again and I can't access it and I
guarantee you when I was 35 that would
not have been the case well you know
what don't don't be too hard on yourself
you're not 35 and you never will be
again right so you just got to do the
best you can and you know what 47
exposures to a word is what it's going
to take for you to uh maybe it's one for
every year adopt of your age
okay 245. yeah uh before we get into
that discussion uh I gotta tell you
about something that I got to do that
originally I was supposed to do with you
and your wife but scheduling conflicts
your your wife had family members that
just decide to up and die and that
created uh travel situations that then
you had to make up for so you were out
of town yeah Christian and I had a
romantic weekend away but I had to
cancel
our attendance at
the Willie Nelson 90th birthday party
two night Extravaganza at the Hollywood
Bowl
I was pretty bummed about that man well
I'm about to make it even worse oh yeah
it was awesome
Christy and I had a great time don't get
me wrong I know I made the right
decision no matter what you tell me but
you can try your best I told Jesse
both night one and night two as I turn
to her multiple times and said things
like I'm having such a good time and
also I think this is the best concert
I've ever been to oh wow because I kept
thinking to myself
this is so unusual that you would see
this many people that you're into and
again they didn't release the lineup
when we bought the tickets they were
they released a fair amount of people
now as I go through this list
you may care
you link you listener may not care about
any of these people but just imagine
a bunch of people that you do care about
and that you love their music and
they're all together in a way that just
doesn't happen I guess this is a
festival experience but not yeah
but sitting in one seat for four hours
each night which sounds like a long time
I did take a bathroom break
and basically having a seamless one
person plays and then there's like a
minute of down time and then the next
person plays and then a minute of down
time and then another person plays and
like they played like one song Maybe Two
songs if they're like a person that we
think we should give two songs to yeah
that was the experience and I'm not
gonna name everyone but I'm just gonna
name some people that
you know it gets it it got started kind
of kind of slow right like they did give
Charlie Crockett the second spot on
night one he's saying the party's over
uh Lyle Lovett oh really got up there
saying Hello Walls back Hello Walls got
up there and sang Hands on the Wheel got
up there insane um you just see him
getting up was there a ladder yeah yeah
it was quite a lot I crawled from uh
were they all using the same backing
band Yes okay occasionally they would
bring somebody else out if the person is
known for the band that they have okay
which I'll explain in a second but yeah
like drummer keyboardist and it was
quite a band and there was a musical
director that they kept shouting out I
can't remember his name
because because I'm 45. back Hands on
the Wheel Nora Jones yeah
and she got up there and she she played
there's that famous I think it's called
Down Yonder it's the famous uh just a
piano song that sounds like an old-timey
piano song and she played it's just it
it's one of those things like where can
you see Nora Jones yeah let's go play
that song that's on redheaded stranger
uh I'm skipping over people by the way
then Roseanne Cash daughter of Johnny
Cash
gets up there with Kris Kristofferson
Legend Who is 86.
but still able to get up there and sing
last time I saw him was it was a head he
co-headlined with Merle it helps when
you've always sounded like an old man
when you sing to then be the old man
that you've always sounded like yeah
that's helpful
uh
of course Willie has two sons Lucas and
Micah Lucas Nelson has a band
uh promise of the real and and Micah
Nelson is known as particle kid
Izzy now and it's funny because they are
both from Willy's fourth and final
marriage that he was currently still in
they've been together for like 30 years
and so these guys are early 30s yeah and
it's just funny how Lucas
they're Brothers obviously who grew up
in the same place I think they actually
grew up on Maui because Willie had a
place in Maui so that that was brought
up multiple times which I'll talk about
in a second
and
they just took different paths yes
they're both musicians but one of them
is like a country musician that sounds
like Willie yeah like Willie 2.0 and
then the other is particle kid never was
doing his own thing right now he's
obviously singing Willy songs
when he's there but I just found that
interesting to be you know okay I'm
gonna take this thing and I'm going to
completely embrace it or I'm going to
take this thing and I'm going to go what
kind of music is particle kid I don't
know because he only played Willie songs
okay but he doesn't have a Southern
accent at all whereas Lucas does he grew
up in the same place okay just a
fascinating study of people
um but Lucas does a solo version of
Angel Flying Too Close to the ground
great song that is
I mean first of all at this point it's
better than what Willie can do because
Willie's 90. such a good song but what
he's doing with the guitar and he's
doing he's basically doing what his dad
has always done very specific Willie
Nelson style of guitar playing but he's
taking it up a notch and he's a 30
something year old dude doing it
it was spiritual oh like that song was
the first one I was like holy [__] this
is incredible
then if you would not have fallen I
would not have found you and then Leon
Bridges and Gary Clark Jr got out there
together
and performed that's cool and then Gary
Clark Jr stayed up there by himself and
did this incredible Blues thing with
these ridiculous solos then Jack Johnson
got up and sang a song that he obviously
please say not Banana Pancakes just
wrote for this situation I want to hear
that again he said I've got a story
about a time
in Maui because you know Jack's from
Hawaii so Willie invited me over and he
basically said that Willie has a
tendency to get a bunch of people
together tell them to go to an ATM and
get as much money as they possibly can
to come back to his house and play poker
before they play poker he gets them so
Stone
that takes all their money yeah uh I
think the way
that Jack said it was he said
I think he's the one that told this
story
but uh he said that
they started smoking like wheelies
weed and
they smoke and he's like just when I
thought
I couldn't smoke anymore we I realized
we were just getting started and then
another amount of undisclosed and also
unperceived time passed
and then Willie looks around he's like
is everybody High
and then they play poker and so he wrote
a song called Willie got me stoned and
took all of my money and he sang it
which was just a wonderful moment that's
cool
um that's cool then Tyler Childers got
up there and sang two songs this is a
two-song situation uh Healing Hands of
Time and Time of the preacher also he
had on a beanie and I don't know if
you've ever seen Tyler sing live but he
has such an intense look like he looks
like this the whole time yeah and
there was a woman behind us and she was
like creepy
but he was great he he whales he's very
intense
okay I'm Gonna Keep moving Ziggy Marley
okay uh Tom Jones
and Tom Jones who is in his 80s
killing it the voice is incredible
sounds amazing and like he had on his
incredible outfit what am I going to see
Tom Jones perform I'm not that was it
what what does he sing he sings um lots
of famous songs from the 60s and 70s
uh very Neil Diamond even
incredible
Jamie Johnson who has one of the best
country voices and also the longest hair
and beard of any country artist
currently yeah he also holds his guitar
very very low he does uh he's saying
live forever
um Bob Weir you wrote down all of this I
like keeping notes no no I copied I
copied it from Rolling Stone Bob Weir
same Blue Eyes Crying in the Rain his
guitar wasn't really working that well
though it was a little bit sad for him
but he did get to come back the next
night the chicks
formerly known as the Dixie Chicks came
out and killed it The Lumineers yeah I
mean I'm not a huge fan of Lumineers but
it's just to show you the influence and
by the way all these bands were being
introduced by celebrities including
Ethan Hawke Chelsea Handler
Jennifer Garner
Woody Harrelson mm-hmm
Rhett McLaughlin uh
uh Owen Wilson
and some other people
um
hadn't seen Willie at all though have
you at this point not yet no
Sturgill Simpson came out and played I'd
have to be crazy and it was I love that
song and he gave us speech he gave a
speech about how Willie Nelson was so
inspirational to him and how he went to
Nashville to make country records that
defied what a country record was because
of Willie Nelson and it was just I don't
know it just you don't see Sturgill talk
a lot he doesn't seem like he likes to
talk and he also doesn't seem like he
even really likes to make music much
anymore but boy it was I mean he does
but he's just you know he said he
retired or whatever but it was
incredible Miranda Lambert you know
we're not going to see her
Chris Stapleton
always great who is the most talented
country artist alive and not necessarily
my favorite but the most talented voice
yeah and he's saying the last thing I
needed and always on my mind he's saying
always on my mind yeah like I don't
somebody else wanted it and they were
like no we got to give that to Chris
staple I can't tell you how good that
was but I am telling you then I bet it
was good Neil Young
and Steven Stills from Crosby Stills and
Nash oh wow got up there together with
Lucas Nelson's band promise of the real
and they sang long may you run in for
what it's worth and now these are old
guys you're kind of like trying to see
through this into the Nostalgia because
yeah not sounding great at this point
I'll just say that but it was I mean
it's them and then finally Willie comes
out with Lucas and Micah
and Neil Young did he blow out candles
uh so here's how they did that
at the very end he sang Happy Birthday
to me
he did yeah yeah I mean he's such a
badass 90 years old as we watched him
play complete with a solo so he played
okay I'm not done with night one just so
because I'm about to make you uh I was
going to say make you wet in the eyes in
the proverbial sense okay okay
um
George Strait
wow came out and they had written a song
George Strait or whoever writes songs
for George Strait had written a song and
I don't know if this is a song that's
ever been released it's about his desire
to sing a song with Willie Nelson and he
sang it with Willie Nelson and it's like
maybe this is a song that's out there
but it sounded like I I was I wanted to
believe that they had just written it
for this moment and that's probably not
true but that's how that's my story
and it was basically how George Strait
had never had sung a song with Willie
Nelson and how that was his career was a
complete wow and then Willie Nelson has
a verse where he talks about it I got I
finally got the same one with straight
and then together they stayed up there
and sang
Pancho and Lefty no
so we got George Strait singing Merle's
part to Pancho and Lefty and he actually
sang a little bit more because Merle
Waits so long to come in they gave
George the second verse yeah
then
Snoop Dogg comes out what
Snoop Dogg comes out and plays the song
roll Me Up and Smoke Me When I die which
is the song they wrote together okay
yeah and it's just to see Snoop Dogg out
there with Willie Nelson in a country
band and he's just so infectious and the
things that he says and
and then it ended with Willie doing on
the road again and then the everyone who
had been out there came out and they all
sung
the circle Let The Circle Be Unbroken
I'll fly away and then happy birthday
and then he decided to sing it's hard to
be humble which is that it's hard to be
humble when you're perfect in every way
after he's saying happy birthday to
himself yeah yeah yeah and so that was
just night one that was night one and I
was like I don't understand how I'm
getting to experience this
and I didn't have great seats as you
know because we just got what we could
but it didn't really matter it would
have been to be close to this would have
been freaking crazy but just to be there
because how many how often do you have
somebody speaking of getting old
that is a 90 year old who can perform on
that level now let me just be honest
with you Willie was always in similar
ways to Kris Kristofferson always
sounded and looked old even before he
was and he does that thing that all old
country singers do where they get ahead
of the beat on purpose and he's done it
where he's two three four beats ahead of
the music on almost every song and Jesse
was like why is he doing that I was like
because this is what they do and then
they kind of forget that that's what
they're doing Merle did it yeah
so
there was that but still okay night two
it's better to be ahead than behind I
guess uh Billy strings which I had never
heard of
he opened up both nights by the way he
was really good I listened to his music
and it's more Bluegrass but Billy
strings was a crowd favorite like people
were really strange people going crazy
for belly strings okay Orville Orville
Peck comes out and sings a song this is
night too by the way Cowboys are
frequently secretly fond of each other
which is a song about gay cowboys that
really actually sang in 2006. Cowboys
are actually secretly fond of each other
Willy's always been so uh I just love it
he's like Dolly and that he's always
been Progressive in his ideology yeah
and his ideals and he's he doesn't do
the whole God Guns and Country thing
that country gets caught up in so the
backwards way of thinking about things
uh but still appealing to the God Guns
and country people in a way that brings
people together that's really attractive
uh Charlie got up there again uh Dwight
Yoakam got up there the second night I'm
glad to hear it uh some repeats but
people singing different things uh Jack
Johnson got up and sang the same song
again and people started talking which
is just a little lesson that like most
people were there for two nights and he
did the same thing
um then our friend Shooter Jennings son
of Waylon Jennings got up there with
Lucas and saying good-hearted woman nice
then one of my favorite bands of all
time the Avett Brothers North Carolina
boys got out there sang two songs they
brought the whole band
Kris Kristofferson then got up with
Norah Jones interesting then Cheryl Crow
yep saying crazy
uh
I think she made some connection to why
Willie wrote that for Patsy Cline he
wrote it for her okay that makes sense I
think that is what she said
Dave Matthews
I'm not gonna go to a Dave Matthews
concert because I don't want did he do a
weird dance I don't want 90 minutes to
two hours of Dave Matthews but one song
of Dave Matthews singing
Funny How Time Slips Away and doing it
in the Dave Matthews
style it was the kind of thing that all
the all the women including my wife
not necessarily it's not that they're
necessarily attracted to Dave Matthews
sexually I think some of them are but
something about the way
Like Jesse leans over and she says we
should see him in concert it's like it
you know it worked well and I was like
well you've seen footage of him in
concert on Tick Tock and he's
he's wild and unpredictable Amy Lou
Harris
and then Lucas Micah
Roseanne and shooter all got up and sang
the high women The Highwaymen song
basically the the classic song yeah
together so all the kids of the kids
other people then surprise Keith
Richards
Keith Richards shows up
did he talk yes he did he talked for a
while actually yeah he's great he and
Willie together did we had it all and
then live forever and then again they
did the whole will The Circle Be
Unbroken I'll fly away and then happy
birthday to me again
and I just gotta say I know if you don't
care about that that was you probably
already fast forward and you're like
give me the time code of when they
stopped talking about the Willie Nelson
concert thanks for giving me that but
this is for my best friend here who
wishes he was there yeah yeah can't do
it all but man that would have been that
would have been nice it's the best
concert I've ever been to All Things
Considered that there's there's that
many things that I was into
and it's very different than just a band
getting up there and just doing
yeah you know and I'm like well I'm just
not going to see that again if you could
only describe it using one word and this
is a transition into our actual topic
for today what word would you choose
wet
sounds kind of Epic sounds sprawling
it sounds uh Monumental Monumental
memorable
meaningful
fabulous
okay hopefully these people have given
us some uh some better words than those
that we can start using next time uh
before we get into our words we do want
to draw your attention to our always
proud collection we are very proud
mythical beasts uh here at mythical
entertainment and we know we have a lot
of proud mythical beasts in the mythical
Beast um
and we've got an always proud collection
uh
that we're constantly adding to so
there's year-round stuff and then
there's stuff that we just bring back
for essentially pride month every year
so go to mythical.com check out the
pride collection a portion of the
proceeds goes to outright action
International zip hoodie embroidered hat
Flags we got it take a look mythical.com
I love the design I love the way the
mythical logo the M translates into so
many amazing designs including a rainbow
design it's wonderful I I love that and
also the design of the
the the new the like the seasonal shirt
the yeah always proud shirt
whatever it says my favorite so far
we're pumping out cool designs
earbiscus is brought to you by better
help if you're anything like me you
spend a fair amount of energy
trying to
let's say live up to the expectations
that you think that people have of you
you know living a life that's focused on
uh appearing a certain way externally
and sometimes you can end up neglecting
your inner life yeah and yourself and
that's actually something that therapy
has really helped me with and even
though we're performers you don't have
to be a performer to feel like you're
performing right for people yeah it's
really easy to get caught up in what
everyone else needs from you but what
about what you need from you right
that's where therapy so useful it can
really be that time you work on just
yourself with no interference from
others and that's why we like better
help yeah I'm fans of better help
because it is it makes therapy more
accessible to more people and maybe that
includes you if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online so you can take
your appointments from anywhere on your
own schedule just fill out a
questionnaire and better help will match
you with a therapist that meets your
needs and you can change their
therapists at any time with no extra
cost find more balance with better help
visit betterhelp.com ear today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
help.com ear
[Music]
um all right thank you for responding we
had a lot of responses to people's like
favorite word let's go through some
categories these ones people just kind
of thought were nice you know let's
start with some nicety
High link right my name is Amanda long
time Watcher first time caller
um I am responding to the Tweet asking
to know about our favorite word yes and
for me that word would be huzzah
uh I don't have a story behind it uh
it's a word I've enjoyed using since I
was little and maybe it's outdated
uh I just think it adds a fun dramatic
Flair to whatever the circumstances
to to be happy or and or to want to show
something off and want to exclaim and
you just survive
it's fun and it tickles me and it makes
me smile
so it's my favorite word to use
highly recommend it I would give it a
try
super fun
um that's it thanks for listening guys
bye
I mean I a word is great when it puts a
smile on your face and sometimes like
the way that your mouth opens at the end
of huzzah
it's like it's kind of like a it's the
biggest smile you can give oh you get
huzzah and you just hold it for a second
and you're freaking smiling
I love that is it Yiddish
I don't know it sounds Yiddish it could
be huzzah and it feels like as she
pointed out it could be a celebration it
could be a reveal like hey I'm gonna
reveal this and you're going to
celebrate or I've you just revealed it
to me and I'm gonna celebrate I'm
thinking about the if somebody says
something use case for this for me
personally I I can I definitely uh could
see you incorporating this
yeah into your vocabulary
surprise and exclamation that's a good
place to be in surprised and happy
you don't think you could no no I think
that I think you could say it in a
serious way no I think yeah I think uh I
I think that I would do it in an ironic
way like if I did something that was
embarrassing oh and then I was like
huzzah
you know what I'm saying I gotta work I
could get a laugh that way yeah yeah
that's how I would employ it it's a good
recovery I like that I like that
let's see what this one holds
hello Big Fellas I just wanted to let
you know that you know my favorite word
is finagle you just use it in a lot of
situations you can finagle the situation
you can Finagle a tool you can even
finagle your lady if you know what
you're doing right thank you thank you
uh it's interesting because I like this
word choice
I would have said finagle but we say
finagle we don't even say hold on okay
this I was hoping for this moment to
happen at some point but I but I I'm
interested I I it didn't necessarily be
the second word so what is the official
pronunciation Jamie of financial well I
got it I got it right here
um
oh you got it okay
finagles
do it this works do been saying it wrong
it's an eagle
um
because nag when you put a nag in it
that makes me not like it but when you
put an egg in it finagle so this guy's
got a favorite word and he's been saying
it wrong yeah well I mean think about
how his world's about to be updated yeah
dude sorry man hate to finagle with your
world but
you said you said it you've said it
wrong uh yeah but to obtain by devious
or dishonest means I didn't know that I
thought it just meant to like
manipulate something to get what you
want it doesn't have to be devious or
dishonest I think that's too negative
but that's the definition Huh
maybe that's the definition of finagle I
think that you're illustrating two
things that I I wanted to have a more
in-depth discussion about okay let's go
um
and it will probably come into play as
we go through this
I used to be
a as many people are a guy who was
I felt as if there was a literal like
right and wrong as it relates to
language right I would say
that is the right pronounced
pronunciation that is the wrong
pronunciation that is that you you know
you're saying that you're using that
wrong
and while I think that there is some
value in
there being like an agreed upon like yes
this is it it actually kind of
denying what language is to begin with
right okay so it's it's expression so
language why not just Express Yourself
language is is symbolic language
represents some reality in many senses
it it represents a conception that
people or concept that people have
agreed upon but just like that Tick Tock
I was telling you about where the guy
was saying a phrase and then he was
taking it back a hundred years at a time
or 500 years at a time and he kept going
and going and going back and it changed
and it became indecipherable yeah after
like a thousand years
to me it's language is just a way for
two people or multiple people to
communicate and have some way of
relating to each other
but this whole idea of
proper English is something that I we
grew up in a place where proper English
was so important and I think it got
really really into our brains right so
just to have a discussion about I think
we all you think that's because we have
a chip on our shoulder because we come
from like
the rural South and like there's a lot a
lot of really thick accents but I'm
talking about the way we learned it in
middle school where me and you can
diagram a sentence into the ground right
we understand grammar punctuation
in a way that like so lost our kids
don't and I used to have a problem with
that
but so even something as specific as
the way that you say the word ask right
and so it's common
uh you know it I would some people might
call it ebonics for people to say x
instead of ask and I read and I grew up
thinking that yeah ax is incorrect right
then I read an article about what the
what language actually is and again some
people might make this make me say yeah
but it's ask it's not AKs it's actually
spelled differently but the moment you
begin to say things like but this is how
it's spelled you or if you've gone off a
deep end because look at the [__]
English language right and we do not say
things how they're spelled we say things
how people groups of people have agreed
to say them
so actually one of the things that I've
been coming to Chris with is that a lot
of those ideas that I had about what
proper English
again it just comes back to it's rooted
in a racist mindset and because if this
is how this community says this then
that's what that word means it's not
math it's language it isn't a one-to-one
ratio to a material reality
it's a translation of a concept as it
makes sense to two people who have a
subjective reality
and it really starts to open things up
and I think it makes I think it makes us
have a softer sort of first of all I
think it makes more it makes us more
adaptable because we're in the mid you
know I used to get on that home and Home
in train because I would say it's
technically home in because it's a
homing pigeon right it's you're homing
in on something you're circling it and
you're getting closer and closer to it
but it's actually more common for people
to say hone in hone is when you like
sharpen something right and you can
technically make a conceptual leap to
those things I used to care about that
and then I was like do I understand what
the person is trying to say do I
understand that they're trying to put a
finer point on something or to make this
thing more Central yes and it's like if
I understand it we're good to go it's
not we're not saying that two plus two
equals five now two plus two is always
going to equal four but math is is just
very different than language so I like
that you've done this so to bring it
back to Mr finagle what I'm saying is
that if finagle is his favorite word I
don't care what dictionary.com says oh
I just want am I wrong but he needs to
if he's the only one that's saying it
that way
then
I just wanted to make an informed
decision it will okay again it will
cause you to be judged by people who
subscribe to the view that there is such
thing as proper English
right but I would Reserve
I I would hold back on correcting him
because who who am I to do that but we
already did it well we already corrected
it to his face I mean I would he's
probably watching the screen do it
through the internet or hearing it but
I'm not if it was just in conversation
man I remember when I was when I was a
kid I said that I was in a group of
people and it was like that there was
one dad
and I was talking about how I was I was
really frustrated
and he was like well that's frustrated
and I was really embarrassed in front of
everybody for saying something oh it's
like I must be the stupid one
it's like no you don't have to you
didn't have to say that in front of
everybody I should have said did you
catch my meaning
then
let go of the correction hey there's two
sides too finagle I can't I can finagle
my way out of it now but I couldn't I
can argue the other side as well because
if you are we do use a language to give
directions
to
describe processes that but then it's
not a correction it's more of like no
let me clarify
that I know what you mean right I'm kind
of talking about everyday communication
between people and it's just like really
come on get us get the stick out of your
ass yeah it's hard it's just really hard
to do it in a way that's not
condescending if you're going to correct
somebody
um what is this one
hi my name's Kai and my favorite word is
echolalia
um it just means like meaningless
repetition of words spoken by another
person and the first time I heard it all
I could say was echolalia
echolalia echolalia
thanks for uh opening this up and I hope
you guys have a good day bye echolalia
a meaningless
repetition of words echolalia
echolalia is this someone who's in how
could you say that in a positive way is
this like a catatonic and what a
catatonic word like well I'm trying to
is this just somebody who's stuck on a
word meaningless repetition of words
just spoken by another person
yes occurring as a symptom of a mental
condition
or is repetition of speech by a child
learning to talk
the the echolalia is really getting on
my nerves or you know I don't know I I
like the sound of the word but I got for
it to be one of my favorites it also has
to
have an have a nice context and I feel
like this one is like oh I'm this is
meaningless repetition I'm bored
I'm not connecting what about someone
who has a it's not what I'm looking for
a goat you know and I'm I know what we
do and we've been completely exposed by
recording ourselves and putting on the
internet for years yeah we all have
go-to words things that we say
we may have gotten to a place where we
don't say uh and um as much as we may
have once done
but
I know for a fact that there are phrases
you said golly a lot more than that I
think I say golly I think I have a
tendency when I'm trying I'm about to
say something to say here's the thing or
let me tell you what I say about think
about that I think that is a symptom of
being let me tell you about it
I think that's a symptom of being
there's two of us and wanting to let you
know I've got something I want to say
it's a vocabulary wedge yeah it's a
conversational wedge yeah as opposed to
interrupting it's just like well let me
tell you what I think about that a lot
of times we will do something
in group conversations where neither one
of us is talking but we we're both
candidates to be the one to talk next to
respond
and we will do this thing that's like um
we will do it we'll give an um a lot of
times in unison yeah that's true so it's
it's like raising your hand
or on like in a classroom or in um
your video chat if you have the raise
the hand feature there that's like the
auditory version of that I have
something to say there should be a word
for that concept yo the conversational
wedge
what is the conversational wedge let me
speak now me just for shortening no I'm
not saying it's what if it was say in
the moment I'm saying it's a way to
describe the concept oh you're coming up
with a word for the book uh and it would
be vocabulary wedge Echo it would if he
doesn't repeat well Echo I think Echo is
the oh no I guess yeah you're right but
what is the what's the word for uh word
logo vocabulization
it's a vocabulizationer
it's a word that means nothing but it
draws attention to yourself so you can
say things that mean something it's a
vocabulary positioner
that feels like that seemed seems like
framing something
I like it but can you make it make more
sense with being the next person to talk
so it's almost like what about ding ding
a vocal prioritization
there's people that said I mean they
used to sit around like a ding dong like
it could be ding dong
you did a ding dong it's like ringing
the doorbell on entering the
conversation
speeched on yeah it's a speech dong
that's we found it yeah that's what it
is yeah yeah word word dong
conversational dong
let's move into some challenging words
okay uh hello my name is Mick my
favorite word is well I don't know about
favorite but it's it's Worchester
Shire watch War Chester shires saw it
man okay Ward
War Chester Shire sauce
I like the bit I like the bit Nick
Worcestershire sauce
it's the unpronounceable sauce
what he calls it we're chestershire
because there is a chest down I think
that was part of the bit Yeah but it's
Worcestershire
I just say Worcestershire sauce
Worcestershire sauce
Worcestershire Worcestershire sauce whoa
It's Worcestershire sauce
it does sound like a question
Worcestershire sauce Worcestershire
as a second language especially if you
speak a language that has no
relationship to to English and hearing
that and feeling like you could have
hope that you could learn this language
I have no need to know this word because
I have no use for the sauce in my life
like what what where do you want to use
a Worcestershire sauce when's the last
time you tasted a little bit well it's
it's pungent and is it supposed to go on
steaks
not unless you have a horrible stake
exactly
it is a great ingredient in things
a few drops oh really gives this
I guess Umami is the bitters it's not
bit I mean I don't know what how it's
basically like
Western Hemisphere umami is the best way
for me to describe it
and Western Mommy
yeah Western mommy sauce
I mean that's a fun easier to say
Western mommy sauce I I love it Western
mommy but
you it's got to go in something
if you're making if you're making a
sauce
you're going to want to depending on
what the application is you're going to
want a couple of drugs I think you've
been sleeping on a couple of drops well
I think the problem is
around the Neil household growing up
whenever they would cook steaks
they put it straight on there put it'll
be like a big
pool of it there'll be A1 and
Worcestershire and you would choose
between the two and what do you want to
be your steak sauce and either one is a
bad idea they're similar they they're
they're coming from similar directions I
think A1 is basically Worcestershire
sauce with a little like ketchup a
different consistency but you can take
it and you can put it I mean I don't
necessarily recommend this
but you can put it in your burger meat
before
and that does a good thing it depends
man I haven't it's been years since I
did that but I did that for a while I
would put like Ritz crackers and
Worcestershire sauce in my burgers
well then you're making a meatloaf homie
yeah but you don't tell people that
Mitch's like wow this burger is
interesting and really really tasty and
ritzy flavorful you got crackers in it
yeah let me try it but now I'm
definitely on team just meat with salt
and pepper yeah Smash Burger type thing
but I'm saying back when I did it but
you have Worcestershire in your house
for cooking uh time we're not great at
keeping up with things but from time to
time yes
um this is all category of tweets we got
they're like simpler words that are
people's favorite this one I'd never
heard of Sarah tweeted rig
now I know what a rig to me is an
18-wheeler
you know or it could be something that
you've set up a setup for like um a
camera fishing or anything any utility
you're doing yeah what's your camera rig
yeah what goes what what's going what
are all the accoutrements around it
um but rig to Sarah is a local term
for someone who has a lot of personality
it can be used positively positively
like what a rig
or negatively he is a real rig it's
difficult for come from a ways difficult
for come from a ways to understand what
now I don't understand oh to understand
because the tone is determined solely by
inflection well when Sarah says local
where what is where is Sarah local too
do we did not say that on the Twitter
profile
I don't know you can you can do a little
um Nova Scotia
Nova Scotia Cape uh Cape Breton
Nova Scotia okay that's a good piece of
information I like this one this is the
one that I can see becoming a part of my
life because I like to think about what
I think of people and like
just but put them in a place in my brain
where I feel like I can understand and
then connect so it's not about judgment
maybe sometimes it is
but um I just I like to feel like I can
wrap my mind around somebody and having
a new word to say well
that guy is a is a rig I mean he comes
with it it's like this is I mean it
comes with a total package this is a
recipe for you to adopt in a place where
that's not Nova Scotia because now
you're you're using a word that no one
around here in your in your life
understands and also even within the
local context it means either something
good or something bad as you're right uh
you know language advisor in this
situation I would say I would advise
against incorporating this into your
vocabulary but I like the total package
of it like this person is the type of
person that it comes with accoutrements
you know okay see now you put your own
meaning on it you're trying to relate it
to how you understand the word that is
how I understand I'm bringing it to LA
in that way well this is the thing
I myself am a rig if you can I would
like enough people right clearly not you
uh yeah it's gonna be tough if you can't
convince me but if you can convince
enough people you can make a word have
meaning that's the wonderful thing about
meaning
it's made you make it it's what you make
it it's what you make it's what you make
so you don't like rig I like rig I'm
keeping it it's mine
you'll come around to it to me it has
physical connotations
oh really I could see a man saying about
a woman
what a rig and at that point yeah that
feels
objectifying because it just
it just it's like something that they
would have said in the Commodore song
The Brick House yeah he's a rig
you know yep look at 18 Wheels
yes let me latch on to that pulling a
bunch of weight behind yeah exactly okay
that's not what I mean but I'm just
saying again more points in the favor of
not adopting this into your vocabulary
what about Aaron V's favorite word
tweeted at us loaf
I'm smirking even as I type it it never
ceases to make me smile or giggle for no
reason when I was going through a rough
time my co-workers covered my classroom
with signs that just said loaf they get
me okay this resonates you like you're
resonating with the loaf loaf loaf you
cannot sound I just don't think you can
sound sophisticated or you know what I'm
saying loaf like if a loaf of anything
is immediately
uh there's it's just a loaf there's no
Precision in it it's just a loaf yeah
it's just kind of like it's like someone
got a handful of it and threw it down
and then there it stayed and then if you
call somebody a loaf
it's not you're loafing yeah well you
loaf
I don't want to I don't want to bring
people into this but I want to bring
this into my life when it comes to other
things like man look at that Hillside
that's a loaf of a hillside
isn't that beautifully feels a little
rounded it feels a little redundant
okay you're saying like that Hill looks
like a loaf
yeah that that Hill looks like a loaf of
bread but if you say that mountain is
such a loaf at that point you're kind of
just saying that mountain is very
mountainy can it just be a catchphrase
then like I mean Aaron says they don't
know
what the reason for it makes him smile
but I mean just when in doubt throw a
loaf out
uh loafing it up no yeah because it
can't it can't be if you use it in a
verb form it's not it's not good it
definitely is about the shape like when
you think of a loaf of bread it's
comforting
and it's it's a little silly it's a
little silly it's like it's like looking
at a turtle it feels exposed it feels
like a loaf is one of the box turtles
least harmful things right yeah it's
innocuous I I think the story of the
Trojan Horse if it was the Trojan loaf
it would be even better because it's oh
it would have worked it's even more
innocuous I think did it work I think
it's fake first of all right oh really I
don't know is it like mythology I'm not
sure is it mythology but uh
I think that's a love we'll have to
slice into later it did work
but it won't ever work again because if
you give somebody a giant wooden horse
that could have people inside of it it
probably in there it's from your enemy
but if you give them a loaf
I mean a loaf of new neighbors new
neighbors give them a banana bread loaf
of banana bread
sets the right tone
you can't hurt someone with a loaf like
if I right was given the mission of
taking somebody out with a loaf yeah I
could potentially
make them stop breathing with it if I
covered every orifice on their face but
highly unlikely it's not very lovable of
a loaf you can still kind of breathe
through a loaf you know what this makes
me think of I remember remember that guy
our freshman year who we barely knew I
can't remember his name he had like long
squiggly hair and he was in a band but
and we were like well who's your band
sound like and he was like well we're
inspired by The Beatles but also archers
of loaf
flow and apparently that was the name of
a band that I never had listened to and
did not when he mentioned them because I
was like you know what I love that name
so much I don't want it to be ruined by
actually hearing the music and it not
being what everything I would hope for
so I've never heard archers of loaf but
I love their name yeah because as you're
saying yeah who's gonna get they're not
trying to hurt anybody are they trying
to help somebody are they like are they
is it like an anti what's it called in
medieval times when you try to starve
someone out of the castle
um 45 again tell me that I know the word
can I find it in my brain right now
starving him out
you're younger than us Jamie
you're Googling it
see that's the generation we don't have
to we knew things and we forgot them you
you never knew him because you could
Google them
Worcestershire
what's the word
when you starve people out in medieval
times
oh gosh
no no Siege
this is Siege that's what I'm talking
about there's different types of sieges
but like a medieval castle seed just
when you like you keep anything from
going in and out and then they're like
oh we give up because we're starving
we're thirsty except over here there's a
little secret Archer of loaf who's who's
who's a Lifeline for this community
right so he's a he's a he's a Defender I
I feel like if you carry a loaf of
something yeah you could get through
several layers of security
you talking about Frenchman's
I'm just saying if I've I don't know a
baguette is a different thing baguette
is too long to be a loaf yeah because
it's long it's hard it feels almost
aggressive it's way too phallic but a
loaf and I'll just carry him around
without it wrapped it there are there
are some penises that are that have a
significant amount of girth so that wow
there may be loaf-like and there's
nothing against that
I'm just saying in general what you
conceive of a phallic thing is not very
loaf like like low it is so it's it's
rounded it's soft it looks like you
could lay on it if it got thrown at you
it would bounce off it doesn't it has no
sharp edges
I think we may have found the least
aggressive form
of Smuggler
of object oh a low yeah yeah yeah
is significantly less aggressive than a
blob even
a blob of something I don't know I think
Bob's hard to clean up yeah get hard to
clean up a piece of it could come off
and get on my shoe like I don't what is
this Bob what's in that blob right right
how many pieces is it going to be in
what's in that loaf yeah yeah no one's
ever asking that can you get a loaf into
prison
yes they will cut it
yeah people probably try this right yeah
but I think that's the classic thing I
think that putting Shanks and loafs yeah
I mean a a shankless loaf is the most
innocuous thing but you know
a shanked loaf is uh quite the opposite
I'm just saying I think there's a
metaphor here for
if you're trying to
present yourself in a non-aggressive way
bring a proverbial loaf
present as a loaf what's a proverbial
love
I mean I thought you were saying like a
physical though maybe you bring your
actual love right because I mean what is
a proverbial loaf don't take wine to
someone's house take a loaf of something
um
yeah I don't I don't think it needs to
be proverbial uh tab likes the word
fella oh yeah happy what a nice fella
angry now look here fella oh
fella fella hey fella hey fella I yeah
if I'm gonna I think that's a good
hmm let me try this on for his eyes
I'm in line
uh for a food truck a loaf truck and
there is a gap in the line because the
person in front of me hasn't gone it's
not a big deal but it could cause some
trouble
um I think a Fel I think calling that
person a fella is the best okay
fella can you move up okay it doesn't
work does it it's too much no and the
fact that the fact that you had to get
all the way it's very anti to that point
yeah to recognize that this is not a
great threat but she said what a nice
fella
hey nice fella I don't close the gap I
think it's like fellas I think I
definitely
you can't single a person out with
felons that's what I just learned so you
could say hey fellas let's close the
line people be like oh he's a nice fella
if it was all guys in the LIE it is a
gendered term yeah it is which it makes
it you know it lowers its use case but
what do you do because it feels like
that was an interesting scenario that
you brought up it feels like line gaps
are kind of a thing for you it's an it's
a source of anxiety for a lot of people
including me and you know what
sometimes I'm guilty of creating the Gap
because if it's an enclosed line like in
a Disney like at a Disney situation
don't worry we're all going to get there
don't worry about it acknowledge your
anxiety and just keep it to yourself but
if this is an open Airline especially
for like a food truck where there's like
you've got tangential entries happening
at any moment you gotta button it up
fellas
challenging for people uh in other
cultures other places that that I've
been
um in like Eastern Europe and I and I
pretty sure that this I haven't been
there but
um
in Asia is this way too like lines are
very very tight America's Got sort of a
loose line loose line we don't really
keep our lines very tight ah and so I am
sensitive to this I actually experienced
this exact concept
when's the last time you went to the
Hollywood Bowl
um
I can't remember uh within the last year
though
I don't know if it was the nature of
this being a sold out event
I assume a lot of Hollywood Bowl events
are sold out
and I don't know if it's the lines were
crazy the Willie Nelson crowd but I
think it's the design of the Hollywood
Bowl which is a beautiful space
but they funnel everyone entering in
this case 17 500 people into two
entrances and
[Music]
I learned first of all take the mid gate
not the main gate oh okay
very fast main gate second tip bring a
loaf bring a loaf
but Jesse and I got into a little bit of
an argument because we were in one night
we were in the main gate line which was
a very very it was kind of a loaf of
people yeah there you go it's probably
50 people wide and several hundred deep
it's not really lines
ascending or descending upon four metal
detectors
that gets dicey and
I she was on her phone
because she's wasting the time she's
passing the time not wasting the time
pacing passing the time on her phone
and so she was in front of me and she
would let a gap form and in this sort of
can't do a nebulous can't do it amoeba
of a flow of people
they're taking they're closing the Gap
sideways oh yeah yeah and so I said let
me hey fella let me get in front of you
I didn't call her fellow I just said let
me get in front of you
so now you could leave her if she don't
and she said I said I gotta keep the cat
I gotta close the gaps so I'm
sympathetic to this for sure you got to
close the gap but then you're going to
leave her behind
no no
and take her phone I I I I would hold on
I'm gonna hold your phone you hold this
loaf as we left it was chaos leaving too
I grabbed her jacket to to stay with her
wow and
she said I like it when you hold on to
me like that
just scrunching up her jacket I was just
holding the bottom of her jacket
so that we would stay together hey
everybody's got to be into something and
I was like okay all right I'll grab my
shirt tail I'll grab your jacket anytime
you want remember there was um it was a
there was a cartoon and a a group of
stuffed animals called the shirt tale
jacket Grabbers oh the shirt Tails no
the shirt Tails I think you could you
could get like a little version of a
shirt tail at Hardee's jacket Grabber
sounds like a political term
you know well we would we would have won
this District if it weren't for the
party jacket grabbing everybody oh I
like it when you do that they've they've
they've Jack grabbed the whole the whole
prison jacket Precinct
uh they yeah they've jacket grabbed
Ayanna really likes the word bosom maybe
it makes me immature but the word bosom
always makes me giggle like a
nine-year-old it makes me picture a
giant attack boob bouncing down the
street demanding a to breastfeed someone
wow that's interesting because to me
bosom is the way to make a breast
completely nonsense maternal it's the it
yeah it's the maternalization of the
breast it's the reason you uh it's the
reason that YouTube
uh there's two loaves won't take down a
breastfeeding video but we'll take down
a topless video because the
breastfeeding video is about the bosom
it's just it it's abreastly as a bosom
it's the functional breast yep and then
if you're just doing topless
oh this is a sexual thing right that's
that I think that's the distinction it's
a good word because it has a z sound in
it but it has no Z within it those are
the some of the best words bosom bosom
yeah name some other ones
um
Rose
oh crap you did it
um what about Cezanne
Cezanne
Abraham had a bosom so it's a it's a
Biblical word I think that that but
that's like a place
yeah it's a conceptual place
of what but no it's a conceptual place
before you go to heaven you can't
remember I don't know it's like a
Purgatory Purgatory thing
but the Mormons also have they have a
burning a burning in them they're bosom
yes so uh that's an Antiquated term I'm
not speaking for all people you know all
the Latter-Day Saints here I'm just
saying in my experience it's not just
boobs it's for them it's it's like it's
just an inner it's in your gut and then
or no it's kind of like a gut instinct
and so if you if you challenge uh a
person of that particular faith
on the grounds of their faith and you
say hey here's here's evidence X Y and Z
of Y I don't think that what you believe
is true
they may respond in some scenarios as
well I know it to be true in I I have it
burning in my bosom in the same way that
like Evangelical Christian might say
well I have a confirmation of the Holy
Spirit okay you know so so I prefer it's
very exciting on the boobs in a maternal
way though I'm just saying it's so
non-boob it's become religious
yeah you know what I mean like bosom it
doesn't feel like an attack I mean there
was a show
on actual American television Bosom
Buddies Tom Hanks right Tom Hanks and
the other guy
starting Bosom Buddies who was the other
guy what does that mean
I mean what's a bosom buddy that's
somebody who's
Peter Scolari you're so you're taught
you're they are really tight
you know
Bosom Buddies we I mean we're Bosom
Buddies right I just don't know are we
missing is it too is it is it two
non-related kids who both suckled on the
same pair of breasts a bosom
is a noun a woman's chest but and as an
adjective I think that's what it means
it's describing a friend as close or
intimate right but do you think Muslim
friends do you think the reason it is
because it's like how can how much
closer than you can can you get than two
people suckling each on two you know
different breasts of the same woman oh
so oh so in other words me and you if we
went back in time to a time when we were
a breastfeeding age yeah and we had a uh
and there was a nurse a wet nurse that
served both families and there was a
moment in which you were on one breast
you're probably the left one and I was
on the right breast you know yeah
that would Bond us for life if you
breastfeed together the family that
breastfeeds together stays together
bosom Brothers
and so I kind of feel like I think
that's really that's really how can we
bring that into into practice not in a
literal way
I'm sure there would be volunteers but
because the literary term if you want to
go literal literary is the loving care
protection of
how can we how can we bring this idea of
the two of us
sucking on
the breast of one woman yeah without
actually doing it I'm not proposing it
okay yeah how do we bring that concept
to life because I feel like I gotta make
us closer I think I think we're talking
about a logo
I think we're in logo territory
you know mid-journey
yeah let's let's put that over on the AI
and see where they can come I don't know
if mid Journey will do boobs buddhisms
yeah if we keep it bosom bosom
please make
I don't know how to do mid-journey
prompts but we can talk to Paisley about
it but we can say something like um
Rhett and Link suckling on the teats of
YouTube's bosom oh that feels too icky
yeah yeah are you getting are you
getting the ick I don't like that yeah
me neither yeah we don't need YouTube
it's true it's sad it's true uh I wanted
a positive thing here I wanted yeah I
wanted for two middle-aged men to be
able to recreate it's love like I mean
there's a connection here how about just
two guys sucking on one loaf loaf
sucking buddies but that let's do that
that's very much like a tit
is a
yeah rig of teats
right that are very low flag and we are
suckling on both of them yep two men at
the book because it's just a bosom is it
a it's a bosom yeah bosom bosom
give it a nice little buzz it is a good
word the more we say that's a good Buzz
I mean word
that's a good word yeah that's that may
be my favorite favorite word yeah bosom
is winning right now yep
can this take the cake
hey this is Gage calling from Asheville
North Carolina hi um my favorite word is
fart lick apparently it's a word that
runners use
um I just like it because it sounds like
somebody's licking a fart yeah so yeah
that's my favorite word thank you guys
love y'all
fart lick fart lick Define it's
interesting that he likes it because it
sounds like someone looking a fart on
dispatches from Myrtle Beach my dad will
give me words that sound nasty but then
aren't oh like it's not dirty I can't
remember what he calls a segment but I
think he taught him
um oh yeah fart let
f-a-r-t-l-e-k pronounced fart lick
Swedish origin means Speed play
Speed play alternate periods of fast and
easy running so basically we're talking
interval training right run hard for one
minute slow for one minute type of a
thing that's a fart lick I'm running the
fart lick
I'm licking the fart run fart lick
fart look it's so it's a it's a Swedish
Orient origin so yeah it's just by
chance it became that fart got in there
sometimes you'll slip you'll slip a fart
a proverbial fart yeah into a word if
you're in Scandinavian countries they
really like to put some farts well but
that's one of the things that happens
with Brands a lot of times it's like oh
do you know what Coke means in Japan oh
yeah yeah they have to really account
for those things
I think this one might have promise
[Music]
link yes
and and that's that's short and sweet
you use this I agree with that a little
bit of cattywampus is bass backwards but
more palatable
cattywampus it's not no cattywampus is
it's just called kilter just a little
bit you're just a little bit cattywampus
but if you're bass backwards
you got completely off yeah that's
completely
backwards so if you ask this is
backwards said ass backwards
construction
term yeah it's like oh your joist is a
little catty Wampus if you're trying to
plumb a line you don't want it to be
catawampus
cattywampus I mean that is nice and then
the way that at least we're spelling it
c-e-t-t-y-w-a-m-p-u-s I mean if you just
take a Wampus a Wampus definitely sounds
like a rideable creature in the Star
Wars universe
but then you put caddy in front of it
and then it it's totally something
different
what makes a Wampus caddy
you know like is is Wampus it would have
been right oh she made it caddy
yeah
honey is this is this Frame well
straight enough to your liking you just
want this is it wampused
no it's cattywampus I think that's it
like let's def let's see if we can
Define Wampus
I don't know if that's how these things
work I certainly hope so
a Wampus cat
is a cat-like creature in American
folklore okay see we're getting click on
that no and but look dictionary.com
plural is wampuses
a stranger objectionable person
so it's bad so Wampus is bad
and it's based on a Wampus cat yeah so
and if you just add a cat caddy ah caddy
Wampus what was it cattywampus
catawampus is not cattywampus it's
catawampus it's c-a-t-a what in the
Cambridge English dictionary again here
we are here we are we're at uh what
about snollygoster a diversion
an unprincipled but shrewd person
okay I'm sorry I got sidetracked
cattlewampus
so we were spelling it wrong going badly
awkwardly or in this well no also
cattywampus in the U.S yeah so yeah yeah
so this is a we got a local version of
this and again K version
and then the US version
oh no Daddy won't they just said gotta
Wampus again instead of saying
cattywampus
a cattywampus is a is like an
approachable [__]
yeah I based on these definitions if if
you if it stays in cattywampus too long
you might be getting into a cluster I
feel like off-kilter was a is a better
is a better way to describe what you
were describing whereas catawampus is is
it's not just physical it's a mild
cluster [__] like you were saying but it
can apply to anything that's going
sideways
cattywampus
I like it because it's taking something
negative and it's making it fun to say
like there's a redeeming quality of like
at least I get to say cattywampus even
though it now means that I have to put
three more holes in my wall
yeah it can only be so bad if it's okay
if things are going kind of want us if
you're still using terms like catawampus
or cattywampus
you're still
these are still some sunshine on your
face you know what I mean there's still
some sunshine on your face still some
sunshine on your face that's right
I don't know where this is gonna take us
but let's go
hey Brett link this is Brandy from
Wisconsin I want you all to hear my
favorite word it is Legume I like how it
rolls off the tongue legume I hope you
like it too thanks for everything you do
legume well it does legume it does goo
it does uh
like beans feel even more sophisticated
I know you like that but just feel it
rolling off your tongue because there is
something to the just the like starting
with the L like the way you you put your
tongue up and then you like you
slingshot your tongue out
it's fun like that is a good start to
any word it's easy to say legume legume
and then you put the
legume and then once you get past the G
which can be Troublesome then you're
with a ooh so it's like it's almost like
you're you're pleasantly surprised with
how this feels and don't underestimate
the the m ending a word on a close now
see now you're you're you're doing it
yeah see like you're adding extra effort
that's not actually there legume so when
you close it down a closed mouth that
isn't trying to do it like
all right
there's a legume legume
it is the perfect way to end our Senate
like Florida
how do you know when you're
legume ends for you it breathes Florida
you got to make a call you have to make
a call how how long am I gonna go
where you going Florida
right what are you gonna do I'm gonna
pick legumes you you just I said I put
an S on it but they're still
legume
[Music]
but to really get the I like to open but
I don't like to ah leguma let me just
say that the experience that the other
people will have around you would be
that they did they don't want you to
open your mouth legume is a great word
legume legume but I will say
in in criticism constructed criticism of
legume as much as we've said about it
yeah I can't imagine saying it in a
non-clarifying way when was the last
time you used legume that wasn't the
following sentence you know it's
actually a legume
no one's like I would love the legumes
please right it's it's a general term
you know a peanut is a lagoon you always
get more specific you're always
clarifying something it's not it's not
specific enough
to be actually utilized so I think it's
always a little bit annoying to hear it
because it's just somebody trying to
correct you or give you a piece of
information you didn't ask for yeah
that's a problem or they're just saying
you want to hear my favorite word legume
oh that's nice that's that's the best
case scenario and it's still kind of
underwhelming yeah hmm
um Misha Pierre tweeted foreign
when I was in third grade I'm 30 now we
would have a spelling test every week
and every time this was our bonus word
to get extra credit do I remember what
it means nope but I think I'll remember
how to spell it for the rest of my life
you're the same word every single time
that teacher was low effort Define
you know if you just go to Google and
put Define
cesqua
beddalian I didn't even spell it right
um
what does that mean what does it mean
characterized by long words long ones oh
poly
polysyllabolic
syllabic polysyllabic that's another
word it's hard to say polysyllabic long
word
sesquipedalian means long and seems it
long-winded feels unnecessarily long
yeah because it is
so it actually is one of those special
words that captures the concept in the
word itself
because this word is too long and it's
hard to pronounce and it's unnecessary I
need to go back to a happier place I
think this will do it
hi Rhett and Link uh my name is Candace
um I'm calling from Canada
so my favorite word is a word that my
grandpa used to use it was uh nubby
Tucker so the word basically
um was in
in reference to things that he couldn't
remember the name of so if he was out in
the garage and he was working away on
something or building someone and he
couldn't remember the name of the tool
or the thing that he needed he'd say can
you hand me that nubby Tucker over there
and it's just been a word that uh has
just kind of it gives me a little giggle
when I think of it and of course no one
else really understands the word because
it was something that my grandpa used so
every once in a while I'll find myself
using it and people will look at me
funny so maybe you can integrate that
word into your vocabulary
thanks guys I love your show bye yes we
may nubby Tucker nubby Tucker so it's
like a Whatchamacallit but with more
Intrigue she had a good voice by the way
she had a good voice kind of leave us a
voicemail
um who is it Alison
the voice of the Swedish meatballs and
mashed potatoes yeah yeah you can do
voice over like describing describing
things yeah nobody talk you can describe
what's it what is that nubby Tucker
actually called and then you could say
the right name for it I like this uh I
don't I don't feel great about taking a
word that was it was so localized that
it may only be localized to this
person's family
and trying to make it my own
but it seemed to me it implies something
so specific that even though I've never
heard it before and I've never heard
anyone else use it I think I know what
it means and it does seem like a tool
used to tuck in Nubs
which would be useful like a pooch
Pusher like that's pooching out you need
to push it in so it's like a muffin top
situation well yeah I guess or like in
in like it's like a shoe horn for a
muffin top that it's a way to get or if
you're just trying to get something into
a bot if you're trying to get a bad
spread into a box you know how that you
know how hard where's my nubby Tucker I
got to get the nubby Tucker to to stuff
my bed spread into this box I gotta ship
it
why don't you just touch it with your
hands well because I've got a nubby
Tucker well if you touch it with your
hand it's going to create another Pooch
somewhere else and then you're going to
use your other hand that's the beauty of
the nubby Tucker nubby Tucker it takes
care of all potential
uh what's
pooches well it tucks multiple Nubs at a
time proceeding pooches a nubby Tucker
will tuck a nub without creating a new
nub which is something your hands can do
right see we're making so much meaning
out of this but now it means something
to us that it doesn't mean to you but it
also sounds like another political term
you know it's like well Senator we
stationed our nubby Tuckers throughout
the facility Senator Morgan would have
won in a landslide if it weren't for all
the nubby tucking that went on behind
the scenes yeah
Brenna this is pertinent and we can end
on this tweet
uh nurp she is a word my dad always used
for something sticking out or dangling
off of something like my Waffle has a
Nerf she on it oh so so when you have
when you find a Nerf sheet you gotta get
the nubby Tucker
so these people are making up these
words that need each other isn't that a
beautiful thing that we've done today
the nurp she family now knows about a
nubby Tucker maybe they can get together
and have breakfast and then nubby Tucker
now has meaning because nerp cheese
exist they can tuck some waffle Nubs
otherwise known as nurb cheese
if I saw if I found a Nerf she on my
Waffle I would I wouldn't tuck it I'd
just eat it I tuck it right into my
mouth my favorite word now is bosom
that's my takeaway
you know don't use the nubby Tucker on
the bosom no need
well actually no need to nubby Tucker
um sometimes I mean that's kind of what
like like a like a push-up bra would be
like yeah okay you got to tuck the Nubs
so a nubby Tucker is a Brazier is a
bosom
bracer or you might have a sports bra is
by definition a nubby Tucker
you know what I'm saying yeah see see
this is happening and also uh I'm here
for it we didn't talk about this uh but
nubby tucking is something that's done
when you do drag
right well I don't call it a nubby
but yeah there was some Target involved
right what were you given a tool for
that no I wasn't did you wish you had
some shoehorn like things you didn't
have to touch your own penis
[Music]
no I'm comfortable doing that
um uh
but it did tend to pop out another place
oh gosh and so I think that's why I
needed a nubby Tucker a nubby Tucker is
for the backside
it's for if wherever wherever something
might Pooch right it's like a
it's the it's the secondary poaching I'm
just saying as someone who has done drag
uh do you feel like maybe you could sell
nubby Tuckers to the drag community
because I'm just really thinking about a
business opportunity here
yeah it feels like you did something the
answers yes it feels like something you
could just yes it's some it's a tool
that gather around
here you're selling it like on the
street corner like in the in the old
west is that what is like a snake oil
salesman it's like oh today I've got
something new yeah and I'll see I will
sell it with oil too uh yeah to make it
yeah make the nub tuck more easily yeah
but if you if you tuck a nub with oil
doesn't it untuck more easily don't you
want it to get stuck
uh well there's a Maya nubby Tuckers
have a have a blow dryer feature so
there's so you have a built-in oil
dispenser that then then dries out yeah
it dries it in place this is a really
Advanced nubby Tucker yeah yeah it's uh
I'm I'm investing a lot of my own
personality USB USB power yes USB power
USB powered nubby Tucker is coming soon
to you all right if you want one
um I guess DM me
um I've got a wreck to wrap us up it's
not
nubby Tuckers from link wow it is
um I mentioned him earlier I think
really strings you would do well no
Lucas Nelson yeah so there's okay
Willie's Willy's son who who took the
route to sound uh somewhat like Dad
and make incredible music
Lucas Nelson and promise of the real and
great introduction to his music is the
first name that's going to pop up on
your Spotify which is find yourself
we've already we recommended that year
to go it's a great song oh we did coming
back oh wow okay well he's also got a
he's got a he's got a song called
Carolina
did I recommend or do you recommend it
um can't remember well you know what we
can this is this is the double recommend
recommendation we're buzzing buddies man
we can recommend the same things
we're getting old we're coming back
around to recommending the same things
you need evidence we're forgetting
forgetting things but I'll never forget
what a nubby Tucker is let us know what
you think hashtag ear biscuits
ironically we made that up it's not even
what it what it means right we also made
up Ear biscuits um and give us a call
you know if if you enjoyed hearing those
voicemails I bet you enjoyed leaving one
let us know what you think about this
might show up at the end of an episode
or whenever we put out a new prompt 1888
earpod one
my name is Harold and my favorite word
is spank
like it was tanky up in here they all
stank
Phil thank you have a good one
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]